i have a question for you just a quick
parting question here right so we have
the 13th and we have to decide whether
we're going to defend according it or
not right and we're going to take it
seriously
so in crisis is usually brought the good
side of government right jimmy carter
created the department of energy because
of the oil embargo and the crisis that
we faced
um
george bush please conspiracy theorists
don't hit us on this george bush created
department homeland security because we
discovered you know new enemies new
methods if you look at this and you say
technology has enabled this to become so
bad
you know maybe it's not a cabinet
position or a government department
um but if the dems are serious about the
value of individuals we have to you know
help the poor and do all this and the
republicans are serious on the
conservative side about the preciousness
of life ordained by god and abortion if
we're both in agreement on that then we
should both be saying
why don't we fund whether it's a
government agency or part of the fbi
to fight something that is now
technology enabled and is running at
speed and scale what are your thoughts
please not the fbi
um we need we need to regulate tech
we need to um and there's not a single
tech uh ceo that has
has said that there needs to be no
regulation of tech right i mean we need
to amend cda230 we need to regulate tech
um it is it is a there's actually a very
good cpa 230 if you can say oh sorry the
communications decency act rule 230 um
electronic frontier foundation is going
to go after me for saying that but we
need to i mean the reality is we have a
choice to make in this country do we
want to continue to have an unregulated
internet that allows the exploitation of
children or do we not it is a binary
choice and we need to
we need to make that choice now what is
very very important and i say this is
somebody who 17 years of federal service
do not let the government lead that
effort yeah
the government should should canonize
that effort but the the tech industries
the business leaders should be the ones
at the table
wrestling over what what that regulation
is and what they can and can't do let me
give you a good example
up until up until deliver fund created
the software platform it was virtually
impossible for a bank to find human
trafficking within their within within
the bank
we created a technology platform that
allows banks to find those human
traffickers at scale
in an automated fashion so now we can
use fincen and the anti-money laundering
laws to start to start shutting down
human trafficking so so we need to
regulate tech we need to enforce the
laws that we have on the books we don't
need another government agency please
know
what we need is the business community
right i mean commerce is what drives
this country business is what made this
country what it is right why we are more
successful than any for the lack of a
better term empire than the world has
ever seen
um in in a shorter time than anybody's
ever seen
it's because of commerce and business
and and our liberty and so we need to
use our liberty as the business
community to fight human trafficking and
take responsibility for human
traffickers using our platforms that's
what gets to the bottom of it and that's
what that's what ultimately ends it and
as long as the government provides those
businesses with safe harbor they're
saying if you do these things we're not
going to hold you accountable for human
trafficking that happens on your
platform
that that that solves the problem so if
you enjoyed this little short segment
from the podcast that we did here's
another short segment to watch or if you
want to see the entire podcast click
over here take care everybody bye-bye
[Music]